now I hope no one will deny I don't
think anyone here will be denying that
materialism exactly pretty successful in
giving us theories of the world that
work the trouble is of our theories of
physics seem to tart start talking about
things that in the everyday sense seem
quite nebulous fields or or about how
space and time might somehow be
bootstrapped into existence from the
relationships between particles
meanwhile we don't really understand
quite where we fit into this how
consciousness and experience of
qualities comes from quarks and photons
there's no way we can predict what
people are going to think about this in
a hundred years from now but is there
any reason in the here and now to
question whether materialism needs to be
extended in some way and is science
the only arbiter of that question well
I'm delighted to introduce the speakers
who are going to help us frame and think
about these issues am i right it's
Hillary Lawson he's director of the
Institute of art and ideas and of the
how the light gets in festival first on
my left is John Ellis who is professor
of theoretical physics at King's College
London and a physicist at CERN and on my
far left is Susan Blackmore who's a
psychologist and visiting professor at
University of Plymouth has the maturity
of materialist view being successful yet
profoundly mistaken and first off is
Hilary thank you so materialism has a
wonderful down-to-earth sort of quality
to it by comparison with the seemingly
rather mystical notion of the immaterial
and mind and consciousness and mind of
God and so forth but I think that
materialism is just as fantastic a story
as in materialism science has from the
outset relied on the immaterial so
Newton in his initial framing of science
really kicking off contemporary science
and providing the framework that is
still used of course relies on forces
forces were at the time when he first
suggested this he was criticized for
being mystical
and not sufficiently mechanical he also
relied on time and space
there's also mathematics not obviously
very material and the laws of the
universe themselves
what are they where are they in this
materialist universe so from the outset
imitate the immaterial has been embedded
in science and there are some
materialists you've tried to get round
this puzzle cuz they just don't like
this it's not sort of grounded enough so
they try to get round this by expanding
the idea of material to include all of
these other things to include time and
space and and mathematics and so forth
and and the problem with that is that if
you extend material to include all of
these things it's no longer obvious what
you mean by material at all and I don't
think you have any content to the term
so if the world isn't material and
incidentally there's another problem
which is I think that that the purely
materialistic account of the universe is
incoherent because it can't give an
account of where the materialist theory
is itself but just as in a as an aside
really so if it's not if the world is
not Material what is it well people have
had you know variety of proposals it's
mind as I say some people have suggested
it's mathematics a recent arrival on the
block is people are now seeing it's
information so people have had all sorts
of ideas about what the world is is made
of and you can make a good case for all
of them you can develop the narrative
you can make a good case it can sound
plausible but they all break down
because they're human concepts they're
not the nature of the world and what our
concepts are doing and what our language
is doing is not describing some ultimate
reality it's enabling us to do things in
the world they're tools to enable us to
do things and if you hold the world as a
material thing then you build the world
like that and you try and make a
material.you you operate within that
closure as I would argue and within that
closure you create your system and you
can do a pretty good job of it but there
are lots of bits of it that just don't
work that you can't quite make any sense
of thought you quite make any sense of
other areas of your your overall account
if you instead you start with a
materialism you say the world is all
mined
well you know there are some good people
in the history of philosophies had a
very good attempt to account for how the
world could be all mined so in each case
you can develop the closure you can hold
the world as if it's all material you
can hold the world as if it's all
immaterial you can hold the world as
energy you can hold the world as
mathematics and as I say some people
having a go at holding the world's
information don't have to say I don't
think works very well but nevertheless
they're plausible narratives but they
will always break down because they're
not descriptions of reality they're the
tools we use to describe reality and
that's why it's none of these things we
can't with language say what is this
ultimate stuff of the universe what we
can do is we can hold the universe in
all of these different ways and achieve
different things with those different
ways of holding it thank you
yeah well needless to say I'm the the
dummy who's a so a going materialist on
this panel as I said before you know my
t-shirt that describes the stuff in the
universe but actually not not all the
stuff in universe but I think in your
introduction you mentioned quarks and
photons and so they're in there okay
there's some stuff which we don't yet
know what it is stuff that we call dark
matter and
like jokes that stack up there because
there's more of it there's a lot more of
it yeah and then we also talk about dark
energy I'm not sure whether dark energy
qualifies this stuff or not so of course
what I have written on my t-shirt is
going to be largely incomprehensible to
most people in the audience side and
that's because it's it's written in a
very mathematical language and so just
to sort of point make up one point of
contact with what Hillary just said no
mathematics for us materialist is a it's
a tool for describing or understanding
or manipulating or using knowledge of
this stuff so you know it is a tool that
we use in our materialist description
although I certainly agree with what
Henry said that it's not actually
material in itself one interesting thing
is that our concept of what is material
I think has evolved significantly in the
in the last century so so here we talked
know for example about Newton there I
think I'd rather different concept of
what is material from what no nowadays
in the quantum mechanical world we we
see as material for example we now see a
connection between particles and feels
that was unknown to Newton but of course
what my t-shirt does not explain
everything right and it's a very
important aspect of our materialist
description of the universe which is
that the concept of emergence that
phenomena that emerge from the
complicated interactions of what is what
is written on my t-shirt okay so this
picture hybrid claim is very successful
I would claim it is not mistaken because
it works
no it enables us to make no mobile
phones and
no electric cars and so forth it's not
mistaken but I agree that it's limited
okay and I'm not sure whether it really
provides us with understanding it
provides us with description and as I
commented in the previous debate it it
addresses questions like what where when
and how but not why that and I think
this is one of the key shortcomings that
Hillary is concerned about thank you do
use it well materialism from the point
of view of someone interested in
obsessed with consciousness materialism
has is obvious problem it gives rise to
the so-called hard problem of
consciousness how does subjective
experience arise from objective
activities in a brain I think it's a Mis
posed question because ultimately we
have to get rid of this duality
materialism can't account for subjective
experience and idealism can't account
for the material world at all easily can
experience in any way practicing
different experiences to look into the
nature of the universe help at all well
here's my adventures at the moment I
would say I'm a bit obsessed I'm glad to
be invited on this panel because I'm a
bit obsessed in an ignorant exploring
kind of way about the stuff of the
universe
so one thing I tend to do this time of
year it would be in my greenhouse late
at night I've been working hard all day
like the song goes out and sure sure
gets burned at night and I have a spliff
and sit there and start thinking now one
of the ways this will go will be okay do
that meditation thing I'm used to drop
duality please join me in thanking our
panelists very much thank you
[Applause]